the true age and origin of a shy is
unknown even to the ash ie themselves
they claim that the dark City has always
stood and will always stand eerie and
foreboding at the edge of the world
until the end of time itself shy is a
city of magic home to blood mages war
logs and necromancer's no magic is
forbidden in a shy in this ancient city
sorcerers are free to perform whatever
spells and dark rites they please
the city is built entirely of a strange
black stone greasy and unpleasant the
city itself seems to drink the light
even the brightest day is in a shy are
overcast in gloomy and the nights are
filled with a terrible and maddening
darkness no man can take an animal to
mount an - I for animals brought to ash
I died soon after the waters of ash I
are fowl in black by day and glow pale
green at night there are home - twisted
and blind creatures so deformed and
unsightly that only shadow binders will
eat of their flesh for shadow binders
are said to be the most sinister of
sorcerers and ash i up river beyond the
walls of ash i lies to the heart of
darkness shadow binders are the only
ones known to venture into this place
the river is cloaked in perpetual
darkness steep cliffs lie on either side
and black ash blows through from the
mountains of the morn the black cliffs
are said to be the home of many dark and
terrible creatures even dragons are
thought to make their lairs here
the further one journeys upriver into
the heart of darkness
the more monstrous these creatures
become until at last you wait before the
gates of the corpse City at the heart of
the shadow Stig I this is a place where
shadow binders even fear to enter what
lies within Sakai what secrets may it
hold as I mentioned in my video on the
five forts George our Martin often
references HP Lovecraft the corpse city
is another example Stagg I refers to
relay according to the work of Lovecraft
the corpse city was built by grotesque
beings that came from the stars and
waiting within the city lies Cthulhu in
his house a troll a dead Cthulhu waits
dreaming relay is the prison of the old
one Cthulhu and his hordes Cthulhu and
Lovecraftian lore is a cosmic entity a
God of sorts it is said that he sleeps
deep within the ocean in relay dreaming
and sending dreams into the minds of men
Cthulhu is a being of chaos he is the
source of constant anxiety for mankind
on a subconscious level and various
human religions were formed all over the
world as the result of his whisperings I
mentioned earlier that Ash I itself is
old beyond measure and is made entirely
of strange black stone
this stone is another reference to
Lovecraft it is mysterious and of
non-human origin and causes nightmares
if you sleep near it it is used for
rituals which sometime include the
sacrificing of children we know from the
world of Ice and Fire that there are no
children found in ash I could their lack
of children be tied to their fondness of
sorcery all sorcery is welcome in ash I
no matter how cruel or how obscene
various gods are worshiped in ash I the
Black Goat the Lion of night the pale
child all are thought to be malevolent
heavily associated with darkness if the
corpse city is truly a reference to
relay and these could simply refer to
the same being the being that lies
within the heart of darkness at stag eye
the beam gets to guy doesn't literally
have to refer to Cthulhu a literary
allusion does not necessarily mean that
all the details must along
for example relay is a sunken city deep
within the ocean sagai is a hidden city
cloaked an eternal shadow in the heart
of darkness but the important bits
remain in the city older than anything
we know an entity waits he is thought to
rise again one day and bring about his
reign of terror and despair he touches
the minds of people and religions have
formed around him in a dream for a
moment bran can see the entire realm but
when he looks too far he finds that he
is terrified by what he sees he looked
past the wall past endless forests
cloaked in snow passed frozen Shores and
the great blue-white rivers of ice and
the dead plains were nothing grew or
lived north and north and north he
looked to the curtain of light at the
end of the world and beyond that curtain
he looked deep into the heart of winter
and then he cried out afraid and the
heat of his tears burned on his cheeks
bran looks further north until he
reaches the curtain of light at the end
of the world this seems to suggest that
he's moving beyond the north and seeing
the other side of the globe he looks
into what is referred to as the heart of
winter and what he sees as horrifying to
him winter and darkness seem to go hand
in hand in A Song of Ice and Fire
the long night is associated with both
darkness and cold the great other of
Mullah Sandra's religion is also
referred to as a being of cold and
darkness because the heart of winter and
the heart of dark has be referring to
the same place if the world is round
then it seems possible however the
shadow is described as a place where
dragons make their lairs a place in the
wake of the volcanic mountains of the
morn it doesn't seem like a place that
will be described as the heart of winter
it's more likely that the heart of
darkness and the heart of winter are
separate places
in fact when analyzed they seem to
oppose each other for one is the Ashton
home of dragons and the other is the
frozen lair of the White Walkers
in the mythology of loved crafts the
gods were a moral creatures often at
odds with each other if there is a being
in the heart of darkness that waits
could there be one in the heart of
winter
milah Sandra's duelist religion seems to
start to make more sense here the being
at the heart of winter and the one at
the heart of darkness could be the great
other and her lore the guy is also
referred to as the heart of the shadow
and also according to Millicent was
religion shadows or creatures of the
light this could justify the heart of
darkness being cloaked in shadow if were
lore for all intents and purposes is
Cthulhu and that would likely mean that
the great other refers to a star the
unspeakable one him who is not to be
named from Lovecraftian lore as you may
know according to Miller Sandra the
great other is a being whose true name
is forbidden to be spoken he is in a
constant rivalry with her lore in the
same way that Cthulhu is in a
never-ending rivalry with the
unspeakable one these illusions are not
exact there are significant differences
between Lovecraft's cosmic beings and
George RR Martin's mysterious entities
if they exist these beings in A Song of
Ice and Fire would likely appear as no
more than abstract forces intangible and
unknowable nonetheless the illusions
exist it's possible that a Song of Ice
and Fire is the game of these so-called
gods cosmic beings that have lived
longer than any men playing their own
game as men squabble at their own
meaningless game of Thrones
thank you guys for watching make sure
you like and subscribe for more ideas of
Ice and Fire